my name is Evan Jacobs and I'm the
stereoscopic supervisor for Marvel
Studios what can you tell us a little
bit about what the stereoscopic
supervisor does what does that mean well
the the Marvel films are produced
initially is a 2d film and then what we
do is convert them in post-production
into a 3d presentation so we take the 2d
movie and turn it into the 3d movie that
you see in the theater when I got you
started in the 3d world
my background is visual effects and it's
actually a surprisingly similar process
a lot of the same tools are used it's
sort of turning the entire movie into a
visual effect even movie even shots that
wouldn't have visual effects otherwise
become a visual effect when you convert
them into 3d and so we're using all the
same tools and the same techniques
really
and when 3d sort of came back into the
forefront some years ago I kind of got
pulled into that world and you know I
was excited by it because 3d is it's a
whole sort of additional set of tools
for storytelling really and so with
these additional storytelling tools you
can you can you know it's like taking a
movie that's black and white and turning
it into color or or any sort of the
advances of silent films into sound this
is like you know - we experience the
world with two eyes and now you're
getting a chance as a viewer to see them
would be the way the way that you would
have experienced it in real life it's
pretty it can be very immersive can you
talk a little bit about the process of
converting from 2d to 3d and what that
involves yeah so converting a movie from
2d to 3d if you haven't had to do it can
seem very strange but what you basically
have to do is with it with a single
camera you're recording a viewpoint but
you can't see around the side you can't
see around the left or the right side of
the image but as you move something
forward you suddenly reveal
occluded areas areas on the left and
right that need to get filled in so
depending on the kind of shot that it is
we either have to recreate those bits
that have been included in some way or
or we leveraged visual effects material
in a case of a movie like this there's a
lot of visual effects will get
breakdowns of shots so we'll actually
get a separate background from the
foreground and essentially use those
layers to create a stepped layered
effect and then separately from from the
occluded areas you also have internal
volume right so when you see a person's
face in real life you have a sense of
the curvature of their face you have the
cheeks versus their eyes versus their
ears you know where that stuff is
they're not just a pop-up book they have
actual curvature and you can perceive
that so we go through a process of
adding that volume into the characters
as well so you mentioned you started
working but in 3d if you know years a
couple of years ago or some years ago
when it started coming back into the
fold
has it changed a lot since then it has I
mean it really is interesting as a as a
look 3ds not a new art form I mean some
of the earliest cinema was using was
experimenting with 3d and and certainly
in the 50s it had a big resurgence so
with this sort of gimmicky black and
white 3d that was happening at the time
people kind of refer to that as 3d and
then in the 80s there was another sort
of period of 3d where people were
suddenly leveraging color and polarisers
to be able to separate see didn't have
the red and blue glasses anymore and all
that so every time there's this sort of
technological advance when we go back to
3d and this time around the big change
was really that now we could make it we
could leverage all the modern computing
tools that we have available in making
films to really make an digital
projection and everything else to make
it really clean and a much more pleasant
viewing experience for the audience so
this is not this is not your
grandmother's 3d you know it's really a
completely modern take on what 3d is and
if you think back to I know for most
people
avatar was kind of marked the marking
point although there were some films
before that avatar was the film that
people really look to and they go oh my
god they real wake in 3d for people and
then you started to see 3d films get
released rapidly after that so what
happened if you go back and look at
avatar and compare it to the films that
are being released today
it actually was very conservative and
it's 3d approach at the time it's it
seemed incredibly immersive and amazing
and it's a beautiful film but if you but
even Jim Cameron has said that he would
take it further today and will on the
sequels because the move the the the
whole art form is evolving rapidly this
before as storytellers figure out how to
use it and what to use it for and what
to do with it they're sort of changing
the way they approach it it's
fascinating to watch
so the first film that I did well you
know Alice in Wonderland I worked on was
a you know an awesome 3d experience but
if you look at that movie compared to
the movies were doing today they're much
cleaner much much deeper also so we're
much more able to take it much further
and sort of increase the 3d effect and
it's it's a it just continues to evolve
is the filmmakers figure out how to use
it yeah I mean certainly as an audience
member having seen the film and it feels
so much more seamless you know you can
it's subtle in a way that just like
transports you into the film for Doctor
Strange though is there you know what
what new techniques or innovations or
has there been you know anything in
particular about Doctor Strange that was
you know exciting for you
well the Doctor Strange had some
interesting challenges that that other
Marvel films and and the films I did
before being at Marvel that I hadn't
encountered one of which was that the
visual effect the underlying visual
effects were breaking a lot of they
relied on 2d visual cues to work so if
you think about an MC Escher drawing
he's playing with perspective in a way
that makes you think you seeing one
thing when you're actually seeing
something else and that's the magic
trick of an MC Escher drawing right
we're doing those but in 3d
in the middle of an action sequence and
we have to do it in a way where 3d
doesn't give away the trick how do we do
it how do we tell that story in 3d
without immediately making people aware
that there's something sneaky going on
in the imagery so so we tested that
quite a bit early on and we've been
working on this movie much longer than
we typically do so a lot of times we get
involved with a film fairly late in the
post-production process because we
waiting for the movie to kind of get
completed before we take it on and start
to the conversion process on this film I
was on I went to London and it was on
visiting the set and and we were looking
at previous before they even shot the
movie and consulting with them early
early early on to try and plan out how
this was going to work because 3d was
such a big part of the storytelling of
the film and yet the movie has to work
as a 2d movie too so there's this
interesting kind of balance there of
like not trying to drive the movie into
solving just the 3d solutions but but
how can it work in both worlds and and I
think we I think we found that place on
this movie you it's but you know so that
the visual tricks are very interesting
there's also there's a lot of there's a
lot of big epic moments that needed to
be told in a way that where we could
build and and so you know one of the
things we try to do with 3d is not just
keep it deep all the time keep it at 11
all the time because you sort of
audience fatigues after a while and I
compare it to like a musical score that
if you think about if you just played it
loud constantly it just becomes all the
same whereas if you modulate then people
really feel those big moments and they
and then you give people a rest and then
you really feel another big moment and
so we were always trying to do that in
this movie and try and find those places
where we could peek and where the
valleys were and that sort of thing and
I ended up being I think pretty
effective people seem to be enjoying the
ride so so you just got out of a
screening of the film yeah what was it
like to see
this movie that you've been working on
for so long finally on an IMAX screen
yeah well IMAX is my preferred format I
was tell people to see it this way and
in particular because with this film
we've actually delivered IMAX a bunch of
additional material essentially a
different aspect ratio or a different
format for IMAX so IMAX is like
especially its it's a premium way to see
this movie and I've seen the movie a few
times in traditional theaters versus the
IMAX theater and it's more immersive
it's more impactful and you really feel
like you're in the movie so it's it's
obviously the screen is very large and
the presentation is excellent
those are important things and and
they're great but the other thing is
this additional material so we have a
movie that was formatted like this and
then when we for about half for about an
hour of the movie for 65 minutes we pop
open to a bigger image so physically get
more pixels so it's actually additional
visual effects material it's additional
characters faces and stuff alternate
shots it's all it's a special IMAX
presentation we put a lot of time and
effort into that experience and it
really pays off I think I mean I feel
like it's it's the only way to see it I
wish there were more IMAX screens
because then more people could see it
but it's really an amazing it's amazing
presentation so we're really proud of it
I know that the post guys here you know
they take so much pride and wanting to
deliver to you guys the what you
intended as filmmakers you know for
audience members what does that mean to
you like you know that relationship
between the filmmakers and IMAX and you
know what we strive to to deliver to you
guys well it's interesting when we
deliver these movies because what we've
done we've had this relationship with
IMAX over many years and and what we've
been able to do is develop is with any
any other presentation that you're gonna
see so if you go out to any theater
you're gonna see conceivably a very nice
presentation and a very nice theater
with leather seats and all that stuff
and that's great but what they've done
at IMAX
they taken our movie and actually
reprocessed it to actually reduce the
noise
increase the sharpness actually enhance
the presentation on a shot by shot
artist-driven process so we monitor that
process and we work with them on it so
it's not something that's done in a
vacuum we're a part of it and it's
actually an extension of our process we
also do additional color grading here so
it's like taking the movie and just
turning it up to 11 is really what we're
doing can you talk about some of the
creative process when you guys started
first interpreting you know the original
comic book series of Steve Ditko art you
know and how did that influence your
process in creating the stereoscopic
effect yeah well look it's a it's a
fascinating set of comic books right and
and we were really excited to sort of
remove the shackles and sort of say
there's no rules now you know there's no
anything we can do and so we found this
out really when we first started on the
very first trailer that we did we had
this shot of four quadrants of a city
kind of folding in on themselves and it
was a big epic shot and and when we
received the shot it just you know to
talk about the way you would typically
do a shot like that for 3d when you're
talking about big wide vistas and big
landscapes and things like that what you
typically do is you don't put a lot of
depth into those shots because because
of the nature of the human perception
you actually would not get a lot of
stereo effect out of looking at a
horizon you wouldn't it's actually be
almost flat right and so that the the
sort of the traditional way to do a shot
like that would be a very shallow shot
actually and we said let's just they're
breaking the rules all over the place
let's see what happens if we just turn
it the other way we just turn it on its
head and say no what if we went crazy
with it make it much deeper than it
should be should be right because
they're breaking rules anyway right so
who cares and so we we went the other
way and just turned it up and just
stretched it out like crazy
and and as soon as we did that we were
like there you go that's the movie
that's the way we have to do this and
and so every time we would get a big
shot
that we would just say like how do we
stretch it how do we go take it further
and really make it a visceral experience
for the audience how do you turn it into
something that they're not expecting
that their eyeballs to do their brains
aren't expecting to process it and so
not delivering a kind of a traditional
approach but you know and this is why I
say sort of always trying to find ways
to use these tools in some new way is
like let's not take the the way that if
you had a 3d camera out on location and
you actually have four cities folding
what would it look like this is what you
would get instead we have because we're
doing is a post process we can do
whatever we want we're not bound by
physics in any way we can do whatever
let's go crazy with it and let make it
freaky and weird and different and
that's what we did and I ended up
working out really well I mean people
get chills when the shot comes on so
it's exciting that kind of answered my
next question but aside from that did
you have any specific personal goals or
goals for your team that you wanted to
achieve on this film it was about taking
people on a ride it's a rollercoaster
ride kind of movie I mean there's
definitely these slow builds and then
these big exciting I mean the magical
mystery tour as we call it which is
that's this big epic sort of a trip
through the multiverse that strange
makes when he's first learning about the
magical world that he actually lives in
it's he's immersed in it and he's
completely taken away by it and we were
we wanted to we had explored doing this
kind of thing a little bit in ant-man
with with their Microverse and it was a
shorter sequence and and not as crazy
but we had kind of designed something
like that so it was like how do we take
that but take it to another level again
just turn it up even more and really go
crazy and that's what we try to do and
so while still we don't want people you
know getting nauseous or anything so
it's how do you modulate that where's
that line how do you find it and and I'm
really happy with that sequence it's one
of the sequences people talk about
constantly it's just such a ride and
then of course in IMAX it's an extra top
and bottom material which makes it even
more crazy so it's really fun
why do you think the character and story
of Doctor Strange lends itself to IMAX
and to storytelling through that
specially formatted aspect ratio I would
say for me it's about the canvas right
this is a big canvas and IMAX is
delivering the biggest canvas that there
is out there so it's an opportunity for
us to to tell this big epic story with
magic and crazy stuff going on and do it
in a way that really does it justice I
mean yes you'll see it on a small screen
someday and your television or on your
iPhone or whatever it is someday you're
gonna see it that way but this the way
we intended to see it let's let's put it
up big bigger than you can really take
in from a 3d standpoint that what does
that extra top and bottom allow you to
do well it's interesting because what
what happens is that with 3d you're
essentially looking through a window and
that's the way that you have to think
about it it's hard to if you don't do it
every day it's hard to kind of get your
head around it but basically you're
looking through a window and what's
happening outside is the 3d but with a
movie like this anything that breaks the
window top bottom left right is gonna
mess with the illusion of depth right so
if you make the window bigger you
suddenly have much more to play with in
terms of getting things out into the
audience space or allowing the audience
to be deeper in there without this sense
of looking through a window there's
something much more visceral about being
there and being sort of surrounding you
in all directions so to me I love that
sixty five minutes of the movie because
it really feels like when it's like the
shackles are released in a way and you
suddenly are just looking out into this
infinite space it's very exciting just
to digress for a moment did you get a
chance to see the movie ghostbusters
yeah yeah and did you have a chance to
see it in IMAX yeah with the breaking
windows yeah yeah that's a totally
different kind of usage right it is I
mean we did that same effect a little
bit in guardians of galaxy we did that
we experimented with that as well and
it's a lot of fun the breaking of the
windows we're essentially or have a
matter
movie that's two four oh but you would
allow certain objects to go out beyond
beyond the mats and it's great and it's
a really fun effect and it's unexpected
and the audience gets a kick out of it
the problem with that we've found with
our movies with our content is that if
it's not a movie that the tone has to
fit right so guardians was a movie where
when you did those moments that fit with
the tone of the scene but in a movie
like Doctor Strange it would really take
you out of the movie you would become
aware of it as a gimmick so it's it's
very important so you look at a movie
like Ghostbusters perfect tone and it's
so much fun when it happens right when
the you know something with a you know
whatever a ghost vomits out at you it's
like really fun but but you're
definitely aware of it your as an
audience member you're like oh I'm
watching a movie this is happening we
kind of our goal was really to transport
people into there into this world so we
didn't want to constantly be reminding
them that oh they're seeing a trick you
know in an int benedict cumberbatch of a
couple days ago he was he was so
interesting how he described IMAX and
like the 3d and the visual effects and
he called it like a whole nother
character yeah you know and to help sort
of move the story along how do you think
those visual effects and 3d and that
IMAX you know extra expanded aspect
ratio helps the story well I think that
you know I've had the luxury of working
on the movie long enough to be able to
see it before the visual effects were
done see it after the visual effects are
done see it and the 3d was done and then
see it when IMAX has done and every step
along the way you see this sort of
dramatic rise and change in terms of the
effectiveness of the storytelling
overall so clearly I think most people
would see very clearly the visual
effects is a critical part of a movie
like this without all the visual effects
it's sort of hard to get a sense of
what's happening you know if you just
cut to a black card that said this
happened it wouldn't really work but
what's maybe not as obvious to people
until they experience it is that the 3d
does the same thing and
and and what's interesting is that we
there are folks in our organization that
really focus on the 2d part of the movie
and so they don't get a chance to come
and visit and see the 3d that often and
when we finally debuted it
they were just floored which I love you
know what I mean you want that effect of
just like they think they know the movie
these guys have been working with the
movie for a year they know what it is
and then they go oh my god I never saw
that thing I never saw that up here oh
my god that's so different than I
expected and it's all there in their
imagery all we're trying to do with the
3d conversion is take the 2d imagery and
honor it and make it better in whatever
way we can
right so there are any shots or scenes
or sequences that were particularly
challenging and and why well we had a
few I mean there's a few sequences in
the movie that were challenging for
different reasons I mean we definitely
dark dimension is a tricky one because
there's no sense of scale there I mean
he's Dormammu is humungous guy and and
how big is he I don't know it's hard to
even tell how far away is he you know
there's no real depth cues to tell you
what anything all the rules are off in
the dark dimension really so and it
turned out great but it's it was tricky
for awhile to figure out like just where
do we put things how big how deep do we
go what do we do there so that was a fun
sequence for us to sort of test with and
figure out what to do to make it
impactful and and yet still allow the
audience not to be we don't want to
distract you know we want to support the
storytelling of it so that was a big one
you know Hong Kong was challenging just
from a technical perspective
everything's going backwards and there's
tons of destruction all kinds of crazy
stuff going on and it's a tricky one too
from a technical perspective to finish
it to make it look good and clean and
all that the there's a scene at the
beginning of the film where where dr.
strange seeks out this guy Pangborn to
figure out how he's healed himself and
he meets him in a environment that has
basically fences everywhere and it's a
non visual effect sequence so we got
ahold of that sequence fairly early and
we were able to start working on it but
to separate
born from his fence from the fence
behind him from the basketball players
behind him and to get all those layers
in there in a way and then repaint all
the areas that are that are get broken
when we separate them was just a that
was a very challenging sequence to get
clean and do right that was just a
tricky tricky set of shots it's not even
a shot you would really think it's
invisible number right I mean it but
it's the thing if you do it wrong then
everybody's like what's up with that why
does it look like that so that was a
tricky one for us and as in the
invisible category for you personally
were there any particular like triumphs
or scenes or shots that you're
especially proud of that you can't wait
for people to see they're the one shot
that personally I was my thing is
there's a moment where strange and Mordo
are standing on this building and they
and they just and then the building
flips and they fall off the building
into a city that's expanding in this
sort of Hitchcock style shot that's the
building the whole city is stretching
the skyline and they're falling these
little guys falling into this into this
abyss below right so we that shot was it
was it's the deepest shot in the movie
it's it's very very deep and and the
guys you know sort of initially we had
them falling very far but then as we
started to look at it we were like now
let's not have them fall very far at all
we'll just have them they only travel a
few a little bit in depth but the city
traveled a lot in depth and so I feel
like as an audience member you're right
there with them falling kind of going
like this so I'm always excited when
people see that shot which not for
competing people have gotten to see it
yet but it's the movie rolls out people
start to experience it but it's wasn't
any of the trailers or anything it's
just a really fun shot so I get a kick
out of that shot because I watch
people's faces when they watch it and
it's definitely one where if you have
vertigo you're gonna feel it are there
any other like moments or shots that are
particularly that you're also
particularly excited for people to see I
think that or that they should look out
for yeah I mean I think I think that
there's another one that people always
miss which is real
but everybody it goes by so fast they
don't even realize what they're seeing
but there's an MC escher shot where we
start looking kind of an aerial view of
a corner of a of New York City and
strange and Mordo or running out there
and then the camera starts to shift and
as it shifts the whole street just folds
into this crazy like one Street folds up
and the other Street folds down and
there's all this crazy stuff happening
and it comes all the way around and put
into a close-up of him lots of stuff
going on in that shot very very
complicated shot and yet hopefully
people don't even realize they when you
start that shot you don't realize
anything sneaky is going on at all and
by the end of it you're like what just
happened so it's I almost wish it was a
longer shot because people don't get the
because they just sort of it goes by
people like I don't know what just
happened it's totally one of those
anamorphic effects where like it's all
about perspective yeah right yeah it's
such a cool shot I know exactly the one
you're talking about
I loved that shot so do you have any
advice for people who are trying to get
into this world the visual effects and
3d stereoscopic effects and all of that
what would you recommend that if they
were coming into Hollywood and needed
some advice I you know it's an
interesting industry it's become a more
mature industry than it used to be so
there are definitely schools that you
can go to now and this wasn't always the
case and so there are places or there
are avenues for people to start but I
feel like what serves people I always
tell people is like a some kind of
background in photography is incredibly
helpful because having a sense of it's
everything's everything we do is a magic
act right everything we do is a trick of
some kind or another and sort of getting
your head around how things photograph
and what things look like when you
photograph them is incredibly important
if you're interested in 3d then
certainly getting a hold of three
experimenting with 3d cameras is
incredibly helpful as well but that's
just the jumping-off point really
because once you get a hold of the
toolset that we have to use then you
kind of can break all those rules which
is really fun so I think that you know
it
there's there are avenues into the
industry now which is awesome and so
there's always a there's there's a
ground floor that you can work your way
up through and and all that but really
it's about seeing a lot of movies and
and taking pictures whatever you can so
you kind of get used to seeing what
things look like when I photographed is
incredibly helpful
so IMAX is coming on 50 their 50-year
anniversary and you know in the last
couple of decades we've sort of moved
from documentary filmmaking to the
Hollywood you know narrative films that
are coming out how do you think imax has
sort of changed the landscape of movie
going 50 years blows my mind I got to
tell you I it's amazing to me but you
know Himax has been a staple my whole
life and and I was always aware of it
you know in the early days with big you
know nature photography and all that
sort of thing and if there's one thing
that IMAX has always been known for its
like an incredibly high quality image
and presentation and and that's still
true today which is which is amazing I
think you know bringing that toolset
into a narrative world and allowing
filmmakers to use it and not just
telling stories about you know animals
in nature or a trip to the moon or
whatever but now saying here's how you
can tell your story on this canvas ISM
is really really exciting and and it's
something that I've really enjoyed being
a part of because I feel like when for
me you know working in film was always
about the theatrical experience I mean
it's you're getting a tell a story a
modern storytelling is in a theater with
a whole bunch of people and this is this
is a reason to get the sitter in and you
know pay the valet and and you know and
go out there and see it because you're
really getting an incredible experience
that premium experience is what people
want I think and I love that IMAX is so
passionate about the image quality and
the presentation and the brightness of
their projectors and and everything else
and so you know that if you're buying an
IMAX ticket that you're gonna get a good
quality resolve you're not going to be
sitting there going like oh man
and I couldn't see what was going on in
the corner over there because the
projector was blurry or whatever that
doesn't happen so I'm a big fan
do you remember the first IMAX movie you
ever saw oh my gosh I I definitely saw
stuff at the Science Center back in the
day the big one for Oh screen movie it
was I remember being blown away I can't
remember what it was was one of the
museum pieces for sure but yeah I don't
recall which one it was to be honest but
but obviously it had an impact well I
just was blown away but I'd never been
in a theater like that I mean at the
time to the stadium seating and all that
stuff that was all new I mean nobody had
done that and to be sitting in a with a
screen that was like below the floor and
above the ceiling and you know it's like
incredible so to me you know that's a
that's a very different way to see
cinema you know if you could pick any
film ever to remaster into IMAX what
would it be hmm Wow Wow
I'm kind of I'm kind of guessing you've
done some of these right some of the
ones that are thinking I don't know when
you said that 2001 popped into my head
right away which seems like the kind of
movie that needs that deserves that sort
of treatment so it's usually the first
one yeah it's like Apocalypse Now that'd
be good and then recently my favorite
one was alien alien would be really cool
yeah that would be neat